i know i haven't posted in a while but
because of legal reasons all i'm allowed
to say right now is this my name's
frasier my name's jarvis i'm
i'm ricegum i'm nikon and i support save
the kids token
it's rewind time [ __ ] coins are on the
uh they come up no or are they are
they're not there's one there's one on
the come up let me uh let me go ahead
and buy let me buy a milf real quick
bitcoin
take us to the moon
your moon portal is out right now guys
it's called save the kids
so the market cap is 2.168
trillion
dollars
and now the market oh
oh
it went to zero i think doing is so much
more than a meme coin it's a multimedia
point cartoon meets crypto like when you
get like a million dollars like that
like easy nothing and you have to think
about it it's like
it's tempting right because i want to
buy myself a rolls royce a lamborghini a
bunch of richard mills because i'm a
stupid [ __ ] i want to buy myself a house
we bought this penthouse
[Music]
for the last six months i've been
working on my own nft project
cryptozoo.com we
can made
art for the past six months bro approval
very specific notes 10 different artists
making art guys all my money is not from
celery
i have [ __ ]
figured out
other ways
it's all good elongate make me rich you
like gay baby let's go you like
by the way that milk token [ __ ] i did
while back
i already told you guys don't buy that
[ __ ] i got paid a bag do that [ __ ] like
i don't give a [ __ ] how many guys
actually bought it you can sell one of
your kidneys and buy some million token
with that right you've got two kidneys
you don't need both of them might as
well monetize one of them so i'm buying
bitcoin at thirty eight thousand dollars
a coin
[Music]
all right we need a 15k
oh like i might play it sometimes i'll
i'll lead you down a path take your
money